[Music]
I'll be honest it's not bad musically I
destroy find him so irritating make
America great again yeah I like that he
started here's the thing is that come on
stop with it he's not afraid to no no I
liked it he I like that he's okay
comfortable saying he likes trumping I
don't care why he does it I just like
Romo it's not like he's a masterful
saying it he's just trying to get people
he was silent until two weeks before his
album came out maybe yeah and he's also
met with him like I don't mind I still
like the fact that he says these things
that aren't gonna annoy people that I
like so you just like the annoying part
um god I think musically he's good I
find it to be a douche most of the time
but I do like that he's sticking up for
that woman like Betty that he kind of
like even if he's just trolling to get
attention maybe he is maybe he's easy
guy with a lot of money Kanye a lot of
those guys do like Trump because of the
way he is with their money it is funny
to watch the guy go from George Bush
doesn't care about black people - I love
Donald Trump Sam thanks for coming I
don't know my p-diddy every breath you
take
oh yes ding no the other Puff Daddy and
the bad boy family before I was looking
to your road schedule is so inspiring
until I see side splitters in Tampa
I know it's I like that Club a lot and
you know let's be honest some of them
just pay good but it's actually a small
excellent road it is an awesome room
Bobby jewel the owner is like he's like
an eighties owner he's a maniac
character he if they got a tall
character he had a tall crown on the
iCard he cost them like 40 grand a year
in liquor himself
guys like that yeah who were such a
throwback I was at and he still kind of
will just I had this guy Rollo Sanchez
this comic future for me last time I was
there and he's super funny
he's like illegal immigrant PTSD served
in Iraq he's at a crazy [ __ ] life and
you know he's Mexican and Bobby keeps
calling him a Native American
hey red blood it's like I'm dying it's
so [ __ ] up he's like he's like he's
like which tribe are you in row vacuum
Airborne Infantry how about you and
Bobbie just takes a sip of his liquor
and he goes well played bobbies also
always got like a hot she's a hot chick
but she also looks like she was run over
she's hot but still something's off
you know it ain't like a fistfight or
something that's how he got her yeah
probably
he's are in a gambling match he that but
he's an old-school guy and I love that
Club I really do like there's some clubs
you do it is a good close DC improv is a
great club in Denver I do the Comedy
Works the certain gigs are there I love
the stress factor in Jersey oh yeah that
can get rowdy it can yeah it can about
Friday Late Show has a bit of a [ __ ] oh
yeah what came in and you said you you
got you are having a thing at the with
another comedian you not gonna say his
name but it's a long story but whose
name I guarantee all I guarantee you I
know what it was about I'm just gonna
write all right pushing he wrote yeah I
like [ __ ] I got laid last night let me
tell you about he like all right Stryper
see in a way that's not real like you
her [ __ ] was gold it was ice cold all
right so I was doing three sets that
last night I was all working out it was
all locking in I had the cellar then
Gotham then stand-up New York and it was
all locked in I get to Gotham they're
like ah Gaffigan dropped in and now
Seinfeld's on Haley said he loves me
oh my god this guy Jesus Christ so he
does 45 so now I'm like I just got to go
I'm telling the the Booker guy I'm like
I just gotta run I gotta make my other
spot he's like no one else is here we
need you to go on so I figured like all
right I got a do chick column yeah got
them last two nights ago show up well I
think people go oh Seinfeld's there I'm
not even gonna go what's the point we'll
just close it out but he doesn't do that
much time does he
Hey
probably did for deeper than gas good
time then another comic went on earlier
it was a whole thing and it's like hot
cheese but I gotta go he's like can you
just text and up we need you here no one
else is here somebody's gonna you know
do checks so I figure out it somebody's
gotta close this thing out whatever so I
go alright alright and he's like just do
ten do whatever you want you know and I
go on and I'm you know they hate me
they're all going to the bathroom
they're like who's this guy he's not
famous it was a tough spot and I get the
light and I got a well I'm the last guy
whatever I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
do my extra time I miss my other spot
it's gonna do some extra time I'll do
like set a 15 I'll do 16 or 17 and now
they're flashed me with the light like
crazy what are you doing and I get off
and they're like what was that I was
like wow I thought I was closing it out
you know and they're like no there's
more show oh my gosh so the comics wait
do you know you pulled a Brendon burns
[Laughter]
extra five for an extra two minutes not
knowing maybe two three minutes extra I
was like why miss my other spot they
don't care he was super apologetic just
go up we need you no one else was there
so I assumed it was just me you assumed
you in the last comedian I understand
yeah and then I got off and the guy was
like what the [ __ ] you're doing him a
favor
well not the comic though the comic my
thing was big I got off and he was like
gee you're [ __ ] [ __ ] I thought I
was glad I didn't know you were here
also if I thought I [ __ ] you I
wouldn't just walk up be like hey what's
up buddy he was like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] so he was freaking out on me and
I was like I'm so sorry that I was last
he's like you knew you knew what you
were doing I'm like you knew yeah [ __ ]
that guy's here was linked out the back
but it was a whole thing and he flipped
oh he did yes I'm gonna write him a
letter or something
don't let it was it 18:51 cuz I made fun
of him I really good dude but I made fun
of him for drinking Bailey's Irish Cream
on the rock yeah I was like alright nice
drink and he said something like I'll
still kick your ass and like yeah but
that has nothing to do with exactly and
of course you kiss actly you'll take off
your charm bracelet and punch me
yeah I know Helio I thought it wasn't
arguing about race he gets into it oh oh
I have it this celery he's great always
about that spot thing yeah guys get
there are comments that just [ __ ] go
over every time I'm not saying you're
one of them but there are guys that do
it and you're like alright great that's
it sometimes
apparently yeah he does do it most once
most comedians are not that flagrant
like if you came over and goes I really
didn't realize you were here I would
have accepted the fact that you meant
that
remember the time what's-his-name went
over on you can we tell that who went
over I get mark get to it the tables
have turned
yes this guy went really long and it was
like [ __ ] 1:30 in the morning and it
was seven spell Chappelle yeah so then I
went on after when I was like what the
hell was that geez and it was working
and I'm ever Godfrey was the host and he
was laughing like you're gonna die this
guy was so angry the guy was making fun
of and Godfrey was watching like oh he's
gonna kill you killing I thought I was
just making him laugh but he was
laughing at the fact that I was gonna
get beat up did you get beat up pretty
much sure I beat you up because you're
making fun if it wasn't a beat up it was
just a you know it was a rough em up I
heard you know I heard that a long time
ago who got who got the best of whom
physically probably the waitress got me
pretty good it wasn't that bad it was
fun we're cool now and everybody loves
everybody did he punch you in your face
no no nothing like stomach no shove it
was more of a manhandle I see sherrod is
a [ __ ] me I know there's some people
don't like sherrod I've seen him going
after a guy that's um who doesn't like
sherrod I like certain fans like but but
he's a [ __ ] animal like I saw you're
so strong by the way man you know a man
handsome I go I go who doesn't like
Sarada is in like I thought everybody
liked Marko's I like sure
some guy in the cellar hashtag race Wars
yeah the guy was being I don't know what
started I came down the steps it was in
the hallway and something was going on
and the guy I don't know if he dropped
the [ __ ] bomb he said something but
sure I went after him and this was a
really big dude but it was genuine it
wasn't for show he really wanted to get
into a physical altercations don't scare
Sharad no man he's one of those there
are guys like that who are very
comfortable he's tough but and they're
bullies that just there are guys who are
very very comfortable I think being in a
physical confrontation I'm not one of
those guys a comic strip one night and
we're just drinking the bar and we see
one of the guys he got into it with
someone there and the guy just comes out
covered in blood and we were like what
the [ __ ] happened he was like he pissed
off Sharad Wow that was the whole thing
that must've been so much fun for
Godfrey though to sit there and be like
he's gonna kill you and you didn't even
know it was happening
so you just kept laying it on thick like
what's this guy doing this is the
greatest thing ever
yeah I was like I'm killing with to
Godfrey right right buddy I am and he
was just like eh you're gonna die by the
[ __ ] and then it came down to
fisticuffs
yeah Godfrey's another maniac he's got
an ERT for quad not not since the
accident like you I think he's mellowed
a lot and yeah I mean million will do
that to you he's sure well [ __ ] yeah
he's not wearing Armani suits he's
driving on [ __ ] a bands at least he
spent responsibly he got tuned up by a
few transgenders at that McDonald's
[Laughter]
that's can you imagine that thing that's
a hell of a story they've heard he's
gotten into it around the corner from
the cellar a few time this just guys
think you know maybe they drink and they
they get but the later it gets I don't
know you've never been in a fight like
that I mean I'm like an older man that's
a dinner one final two yeah it is the
one around the corner paid for being in
the West Village
yes Shady
that's really one that's right by The
Village Underground there thank you yeah
that's the one with that famous video
you could probably pull it up there
t-dog about the woman come behind the
counter with a like a big metal you know
pipe is that there that was there it's a
classic video your way McDonald's I'm
loving it
I love it yeah what's your way Burger
King yeah who's have it your way at
Burger King hold the pickles hold the
lettuce hold though whatever just
special orders don't upset us we ask is
that you let us serve it your way why
would they have let us twice
Colet us and let us there it is rayon
that's the that's the McDonald's huh
ass-whooping that's the one baby fifty
dollar bill this is actually a different
video than the one I saw but it's still
the same incident it's pretty much well
there's just so many over here yeah this
is different oh wow when I saw is
black-and-white footage and the guys
back there over the counter with a pipe
who beat up whoo-hoo McDonald's but they
have to fight hide Oh brutal oh yeah
same with bodega guys they gonna like
you know kick ass and pull guns I love
seeing the McDonald's employees snap on
somebody who's rude though cuz I really
a [ __ ] job just a day of having to deal
with everybody
and finally the wrong person says the
wrong thing well I love when the wrong
person when they get on a line to a
certain degree and they try to get
physical and then the person pulls out a
[ __ ] pot yeah this is gonna be a quick
one wouldn't you be sky would be scared
to hit somebody with a piece of metal
but there are some people where if you
push them to that point they pick up
metal they're just gonna beat your
[ __ ] brains no I think you got to go
black outrage right I like it that that
fear of like knowing what the
consequences are after I hit this person
with a frying pan has to go away before
you hit them with a frying pan I drop
like Nicolas Cage and Conair though and
you go to that black up and then your
life is over oh yeah right done I was
right for a minute when you kill the guy
right right right after that I like him
better as castor Troy yeah did he [ __ ]
his wife in that Travolta's wife as
Travolta yeah that's right that's
exciting and then but she didn't she
knew was him because he didn't do
thing with the touch of the face which
is never really romantic quality mark
not a Hollywood writers mark loves weird
cuckold stuff yes he does he always
comes in with some weird cockles luck or
like that's right yeah like last time
you came in it was like maybe I mean I
guess it's not technically cuckold it's
like the girl who was giving the [ __ ]
and then realized like she had made a
mistake because she was engaged and her
facial expression changed when mr.
Karlson was molesting dudley and made
arnold watch sexy stuff come on watch
the cartoon Dudley how good a job do
they do with that facial surgery and
face off I mean that doctor nailed it I
mean on his kind of little scar
yeah and they healed quickly there was
no rejection drugs that guy was good I
can't believe they could do that yeah
but they did the whole body right if
there was sex involved that's true yes
that's pretty amazing yeah I get from
his face right but it was just a little
something was a little off Gina Gershon
man oh yeah she's still hot yes yes very
hot what was the last thing she was she
was just in something not too long ago
he was in curb uh-huh
she was in crashing maybe that's why she
was in uh eastbound and down yeah yeah
very hard she's she's 55 Wow
I thought she was a mark and I like
older women
really you don't like old not even as
friends I'm the office
older I don't I can't deal with young no
I mean not you know like what do you
like him generally ten years younger
than you they were gonna say something
else yeah no I want someone thirty is
far 30s a good age 28 to 30 is a great
younger and I wanting is more than
enough I would date 20 I would date 20
or 20 years younger than you oh yeah 20
to 30 years younger but but thirty years
old is a perfect age 28 cuz they're
[ __ ] you know they got some maturity
but there's still like not desperate for
a baby right Wow like at 45 they've kind
of like that's it absolutely yeah you
know I mean there's just a sure I'm when
I'm not desperate well this is not
happening
god bless her okay you're not interested
in that [ __ ] no with that [ __ ]
with that with that dresser drawer womb
no I'm not do you mean post menopause
whatever yeah 45 50 20 180 variety abut
you would [ __ ] like a 55 year old woman
she was hot I have yeah thank you
many times I lost my virginity we're
like a 50 year old I'm 49 I can't
believe I'm saying I mean ice like
that's in my that's in my wheelhouse now
yeah it's literally a peer yeah age
appropriate I i I'm deaf they're hard to
I I'm in I love it well it's a
humbleness you know they're old they're
little crinkly they're crackly they're
gonna die soon they can't have kids they
don't of defeat is good yes right
they're like guys in a way like they get
oh you don't want to touch me I get it I
get it you know that's fun it's humble I
mean she is very attractive she credible
bass yeah very wide blue glasses that is
a hot look there - what cuz they're over
like the game at that point they're not
used to there there's no bullet I feel
like there's like young girls put you
through [ __ ] right there's like oh
there's these tests you gotta pass in
these games because they've so many
options right sure they don't know what
they write they also have to convince
themselves that you've earned [ __ ]
them so they don't feel like pigs
someone who's 51 is like yeah I'd love
some lasagna come eat my [ __ ] right
they don't need to tend yes and they
want it they're horny as they're horny
is us yeah they are can they understand
mortality
some of the guys that [ __ ] are dead
yet divorce their kids are grown I like
that they understand mortality it's like
I got a [ __ ] yeah they do understand
that sooner or later this is gonna run
out I'm not gonna be able to do this
anymore I got to do some more yeah yeah
they appreciate it like you're so young
you're [ __ ] me I can't believe it I
really do you think so sorry oh yeah
yeah older women are good for that you'd
[ __ ] all the woman I mean I have oh
man there was a what I was going crazy
on tinder I was just trying to do crazy
[ __ ] and there was some lady who had
pictures of like her kids and her
grandkids on tinder grandkids yeah you
[ __ ] your grandma yeah she's probably
she's probably 60 it was an LA and she
was pretty pretty sexy for a 60 year old
but there was a time where you're you're
looking you're like oh my god this is
like she's like my mother
Wow did you have a chair in the shower
[Laughter]
she gave you a lemon drop to an older
lady once who lost her her menopause
patch in my bed Oh
menopause patch something to help
regulate her hormones she's going
through menopause she's trying to quit
pretty disgusted by that no it's just
something about it just just said yep
she is this old
yeah it's reality coming and crashing
down yeah toughest Cub Scout patch to
get Metapod yeah ya know the menopause
patch itself is not that sexy no no but
it does remind you of what I just did
like that's kind of a cool thing yeah in
the dative specific perspective oh yeah
and then I made I made this old lady
squirt and she just lost never done this
word head well no she was like she was
like the girl from the woman from LA she
was playing like she's 60 year old
squirt I 50 you think she had lost
control of her faculties
she did know wasn't that what do you
think that was sexually these it faculty
[Laughter]
and I was with the squirtle once and she
was chugging have you ever had this
they're chugging water before she's a
guy have to hydrate chug water before
you squirt that's yes the Olympics yeah
because what happened to me drink a
bunch of water do you squirt it out into
your piss
well I piss but I'm not a vagina oh
you're losing fluids you gotta drink
water
hey my sweat yeah is coming out of your
forehead was it clean squirt water now
it wasn't families were dying I know how
to do it you know get a girl squirt
[Laughter]
what's the trick teach us Oh squirt or
one it's uh can you do it on Nico my man
[ __ ] toys up and then pull in it's it's
there's a lot there's like a lot
involved it's in and up and then you
have to sort of just monitor what she's
doing how she's reacting to it if she
tenses up you can't be a selfish lover
it's like Nintendo Chi coach for adults
oh [ __ ] it's three B's you gotta go back
to the beginning
the ball on the Great Santini come on
use court I don't I can't monitor a
woman's feelings yeah to squirters in my
life one when I was like 20 or 21 I
would only eat her [ __ ] and she would
squirt on my chin I've never made a girl
squirt from [ __ ] you only from going
down on her it was two different women
or three women in my life and that's it
very rare I've had that once with the
eat out it's hot because you're going
you're looking at [ __ ] annually yes and
I coach your chin and I would there
would be a spot like the size of a
manhole cover on the bed it was amazing
what to do yeah love deciding that the
first girl you've been with that's been
able to leave fluid on your chin no
there's been a lot of them but this was
this actually was the first orbit if any
after I first the manhole I thought that
I took for granted I was a young guy oh
my god this probably pretty common
you're gonna learn how to do it like
Troy I don't know Patrice could do it
too of this big dumb long he had [ __ ]
like you know eight-inch fingers I have
a small hands encouragement it's really
nice it's not hard do they like it or is
it just a show really that girls let me
freak out okay do yeah just because a
lot of times they just they don't even
know they can do it right you you've you
with your fingers can make up squirt
yeah do you talk to him
yeah of course make up we we make it we
we yes I'm really on TV single for daddy
yeah tinkle on Daddy's wrist The Rolling
Stones documentary they said that the
seats were all wet a like during those
first couple years of concerts cuz it
was so pent up London you know you're
all the repressed women they said the
seats will be wet and Wow that is to
clean up those children bottom sweat
sweat just sweat just a sweat and their
tears the girls crying i watch stones
footage from I was them doing under my
thumb who's a really chilling version of
it I was great
from like Top of the Pops one of those
shows in 1965 and you're watching these
girls like Mickey's like 20 and these
girls are screaming and crying and it's
crazy to see that it's like a Bieber
reaction but you know that all of those
women 1965 it's 50 years ago I mean
they're all they're 65
is like so if it's like such an upbeat
song under my thumb but he's like it's
about [ __ ] just like owning this girl
in the relationship right
yeah what's about her turning the
turning the tables on a girl yeah it's
not like dancing to it that's that's how
good they were right right
that's like rap from like the 60s yeah
totally top of the pie starts 1965 I
think also that might be yeah right
there yeah brown-skinned girl all that
[ __ ]
brown sugar whatever it was yeah Ronson
girls man how can we taste so good right
yeah just the girls
there's brown-eyed girl
thank you that's brown skin what is it
they change it for the radio it is weird
to watch the women just use when they
show cluster so that girls screaming
like I want to how many dozen they're
dead is that now still [ __ ] girls
that age that's the beauty of Mick
Jagger yeah is he never got tired of he
just had a kid this is what it's like
for your shows though how annoying is he
you have to cry for the reasons like
when they realize they've spent on their
ticket but die yeah he just had a baby
with some girl you know much whose
[ __ ] family must hate the fact that
he's still dumping out kids I know my
that's another [ __ ] person to split
the Jagger fortune yeah but he'll never
run out of money no I mean the stones
have enough but it'll be tough once it
starts getting split up amongst the kids
it's not gonna go generationally down
that far five or six made more out of
fine he's less than like the average NFL
player I know how many does he have wait
that's Georgia May is [ __ ] Gore's are
cute Kweisi how many kids these guys get
quite a few eight oh it is eight hey
it's a lot that's a lot there's a lot
that's play seventy million each time
I'm here I'm not crying over there viii
yeah but I mean well you would you got
90 million coming and you lose 20
million cuz pops couldn't [ __ ] pull
out [ __ ] then we you stopped coming
who's the wife bang and that old
wrinkled the wife any any woman who he
would [ __ ]
she said she's our she's it from Lincoln
Center she's cute oh she's really she's
a dancer I think from Lincoln Center
uh-huh twenty-eight that's all right now
you have a convert when you're in your
seventies and you've lived that life how
do you possibly have a conversation with
someone it's like what do you talked
about someone that's sick like I know
what you mean
but say yeah you know whatever you want
to talk about you just talk about it
I've talked cuz I've talked to you know
twenty five-year-olds that were
fascinating and fifty year olds that
were duds yeah there are like I've been
out with women in their 40s that sucked
mm-hmm the rock just had a baby I know I
can greet I congratulated my friend I
know I saw that it was so [ __ ] lame
why you been on Twitter and you're like
Congrats like because I heard about it I
was what would he tweet you back yes oh
did you write oh I heard you had a
pebble two friends tweeting each other
you and DJ yeah Twitter a couple of
friends because congratulations was how
I felt when I heard it I don't have any
kids I don't have a frame of reference I
didn't have anything deep to say I'm
happy for me seem happy he put out a
nice Instagram third daughter it is yeah
well I always wonder you know because
Jim Morrison was impotent I've heard
that you fight the drugs yeah yeah but I
was wondering you know you hear one of
these stallion men these sex gods and
then what's the real deal what are they
really hiding you know it's
overcompensation
not the rock is he I'm guessing he's
doing like you know he's so big I don't
know if he's on TRT or anything but I
would hope he is and you know if he's
not he should because you know that's he
lifted that many weights why not right
tell you something
he's impregnated two women that's not
bad well here about like David Spade and
I bet he's amazing in the bedroom like
everybody said Spade has the hottest
girls of all time yeah cuz he's funny
he's not a bad-looking guy and he's
funny yeah well he should I gotta say
showed up to Schumer's winning and he
walked in he's about four eight and he's
got a blonde mullet and weird cheesy
facial hair and every girl was like
David Spade he like walked in worked the
room and left from there growing up too
they'd rather wash all this Tommy Boy
and all these funny movies so it's
almost like Bob Saget Bob Saget will
swim in [ __ ] for the next 22 years yeah
who's women growing up watching that
show and that by the time they're only
another 12 when they're watching him
then he meets him in that 25 doing oh my
god I have to eat his load yeah or
holiday phrases I think they would
phrase it that way that's a I went to
watch some of those full house they
man they're so [ __ ] bad and funny
well like I was I was just Macky and I
were just watching like as a gag just
like some of the old like her friend
gets in a car crash and stuff like a
conversation I didn't see you and Joe
Mackey just watched four house I feel
like we're just doing this as a gag this
is ironic pretty girls I couldn't think
that's good Joe Paterno Wow
maybe they're just girls he's been to
movies with no no hace keep going hi
Jesus well that's not Rivera she's oh
she's English she was in glee she's like
ridiculous hot yeah like Hannibal Lecter
had to wear in the world Carmen Sandiego
my mother Botha think he'd be good for
the family had no idea what I was doing
under gateway 15 minutes to download a
golden shower video back in the dollar
prompt days ya see the C prompter you
enter a free cold shower videos I never
forget downloading a girl pissing I'm
not knowing where it wound up Wow you
get the preview with a thumbnail back
then you just have to [ __ ] go by the
description cuz I yes I own anything
it's before cos ah that Kasab was on
[ __ ] I had my laptop this was before
that I don't even remember where I got
it yeah I remember printing out naked
pictures anyway just rank each line
would take a half hour yeah no no just
keep them in my pocket dude I used to
use my dad's printer to print out porn
and sell it in school when I was like
sixth grade Wow and I remembered this
teacher busted me and he was like this
old gay man who just was a good great
guy and he was like I'll just tell the
boys you were selling lingerie photos
old tail yeah that's like churning
butter or something yeah selling porn
pics yeah who would buy them some kids
with a few extra dollars on I guess so
yeah that generation that would be
popular sale yeah how old you I'm 31
okay sister I'm surprised it even that
long I don't know there's a big business
in my school people would consider on
high speed and an internet was just kind
of starting and like a kid would find
another kid like a nerdy kid who had
high-speed Internet in his house and he
would kind of bully him to let him go
over his house and download music and
you would pay him like ten dollars for a
mix CD and then he would go over to this
other kid's house with the fast internet
and download your mix CD and give it to
you the next day but that's all I mean
it cost him nothing
it's a blank CD mmm-hmm well that was
like a big business for them back then
those were the days yeah people this is
dick heads on Twitter no yeah you think
that's not on my Twitter like I did a
joke about stormy Daniels about going
trumpeter back to work whatever it's a
stupid joke it was stupid but you know
she responded to it oh wow
I saw that yeah she was okay yeah she
was fine I would I do this is a dumb
just two jokes I read something that she
was going back to porn so Java and then
some guy I said Trump is getting people
back to work or something here is the
joke it said I hear stormy Daniels is
doing porn again say what you want about
Donald Trump but he gets people back to
work he's stupid job Twitter joke I like
it exactly not a major [ __ ] just oh
this is a story I read dumb people would
[ __ ] these P and she went back and you
can yeah you can go on Jim's feet and
see what she wrote back sure nothing
back there
nothing terrible she wrote back I never
left it I roll and I wrote something to
her that was it wasn't horrible yeah
except I never left I roll well you know
then I just responded her but so some
guy writes that why'd she write I roll
there's a modal you ask so there's
emotional with the eyes rolling in it
you know to write the words I roll but
it's amazing how many people like one
guy wrote Trump gets people back to work
please
the only thing he's been getting back
his pocket has been money and his family
business wake the F up and it's like why
don't you just hang yourself know who
analyze jokes deserve the death
whatever don't laugh why right see with
Schumer's movie coming after like what
this really says about female beauty and
you're like just see the [ __ ] movie
or don't don't write we don't need any
more think pieces on comedy right please
stop kill yourself it's all narcissism
this is how I feel people if they taking
it seriously comes for lining his
pockets right [ __ ] up
I get mad with somebody through the
truth that you do know let him in semi
it's about time it's bath time somebody
told you what it is your words they
count man they're hot that is true what
do count yeah they are the precursor to
action that's right so I've been trying
okay I like the people that are like why
don't you dig a grave you unfunny
[ __ ] like Jesus and they're like what
I was kidding decipher through Twitter
for a stranger but that when you say I
was just kids like what wasn't a good
joke that's okay that was a good joke
that's so insensitive kill yourself
yeah the irony yeah they really yeah
they get very upset ya know why but
they're gonna see this they're gonna
push people away like you know Schumer's
movie comes out they're like this is
actually offensive to women and it's
like well you're just gonna piss her off
again or piss out all of us off to where
we just stop doing stuff didn't she have
a good opening weekend yeah dude she was
number one comedy yes she did pretty
well I mean that thing it's not gonna do
well and she's like 13 million the first
day Jolla said it was good I haven't
seen any I'm gonna see this week yeah
also heard the Krasinski movie was
amazing what's that I want to see that
you know everybody says it's so good be
a quiet place my place yeah million
dollars the first look at Dave and
shorts oh my god that's hilarious
Dave it's like a Mafia don you don't
expect the semen short okay right I saw
in the daylight once it was terrified
by the way I just did Moontower they'd a
ping pong contest
Judah Friedlander is so good at ping
pong it's like an Asian world champion
it was like Forrest Gump and it was like
real pink that was like a real ping pong
thing and all these people knew oh my
god Judah like he knew all the pros he's
in the scene I'll kill him a ping pong
no not no idea dude he's ten feet behind
the table
a newspaper in one hand and a paddle on
the other just he's apparently one of
the best slaughter you have no idea I
would love to see a try does he serve
hard crazy serve he gets down real low
we got footage of it well he couldn't
publicly play ping-pong if he wasn't
great at it because it would just
destroy his whole gimmick that's right
him and realize he's an athlete you
don't know what you're doing
[Laughter]
he's like a hobo savant I'm more
impressed with the guy serving him you
want just one shot that keeps showing
over it over yeah this is [ __ ]
illusions and this is back in his fatter
days yeah he's not good he's average of
ping-pong I'm better really water I'm
museum piece if they think father that
is funny
killing it he was so nervous cuz he's
like I got a shine here but he knows I'm
good that's [ __ ] great yeah we're
sounded so good so fun so fun does it
this club comedy off Broadway lexington
kentucky great club there's an awesome
club dude kentucky I went to Keeneland
the racetrack it's like it's a good
thing there it's like everyone it's
packed like the whole city like
everyone's dressed up for this oh yeah
baby I want some money
it was [ __ ] fun it's packed everyone
looked like like Django villains they're
so [ __ ] it was great how much you win
i only won like 80 bucks but it was like
you know i was i was hanging out of his
head a drank it's nice they've like
martini carts and [ __ ] horse racing
seems so [ __ ] tense this so easy to
lose yeah tony soprano used to get so
pissed when he lost his horse racing
yeah that was a good offer yeah yeah
Isabella Rossellini oh my
pie-o-my they play that Dean Martin song
at the end my wife on my pony and made a
great song yeah did you have a fun horse
name I did I think was like lover boy
one of them's called screenwriter which
I kind of like who farted who farted who
farted the jockeys are
adorable yeah they're just like 120
pounds they don't like that description
I don't think the women are going crazy
I like walking by women I think taking
selfies with the horses and [ __ ] it's
great
oh yeah women love horses yeah I've seen
video I liked it tonight yeah I did for
this night so I did a piece of the
Kentucky Derby years ago where they sent
me later it was weird to like just have
a live field piece and it was gonna wear
that ridiculous suit right I wore a
dress interviewed Fred Thompson was
wearing a dress
Thompson yeah dude I heard that he used
to go to Houston like take a limo to a
pickup truck to go to his rallies how
would a common man you're sure yeah
that's so funny I respect that law and
order man yeah
how many politicians were regular son in
law and order right he was anyways I
could never get on law and order really
never got it audition I didn't get it
how many times did you audition few many
times and they didn't big didn't choose
you didn't a lot of people have done law
and order everyone nice to not everyone
know I haven't been about never do yeah
did anything if I asked him he didn't
want to do it no he said he couldn't get
on you couldn't know weird does that
sound weird no no I don't try never even
audition right Sam
now they just asked me straight up and I
said no turn it down yeah got a callback
recently yeah I've never gotten I've
auditioned for 8,000 things I've never
got one hmm not one Oh Sam yeah I'm a
I'd never get anything yeah I didn't
carry remember that time you took your
shirt off yes that was fun I thought I
was just like do stupid [ __ ] to at least
make it funny for me what was this one I
was for Amy's movie I just took my shirt
off in the audition because it was
supposed to be like an idiot
wait well you got it
wait we didn't put you in she made you a
fashion it was like this was like years
ago all right yeah
seems strange is funny yeah it's funny
to take the shirt off were you in
trainwreck yeah I got cut out me too
you had a good scene too all right a bit
I saw the scene I was like I must have
sucked but then I saw it I was like no
is actually good it wasn't it wasn't bad
I they told me why they did it [ __ ]
comfort time they say was a lot too long
a scene and the guys bill hader and her
bill stole a horse and carriage
Wow and they thought I was a horse
driver and they said it just didn't fit
that he would do that Dan I would've
been a great scene you know it's funny
before Kurt's before our Kirkus Kurt was
riding in that movie before they even
shot it when he just tell me about it he
was like yeah I'm trying to get through
through something else it doesn't like
he was even saying before they shot it
it didn't make sense to him that they
were doing that yeah yeah so cut out of
an Apatow because they were so long
anyway I got a crash in the season yeah
yeah I did a roast with Matteo Lane I'd
good lines to it sucked it like not get
in maybe work on that you write those
jokes yeah yeah did you know you got cut
out or did you I didn't watch they just
send me an email they're like we're
sorry but huh but it was fun I was
roasting Matteo Lane you know gay comics
for yeah yeah I said you uh you're from
Brooklyn but you spend all your time in
Queens
yeah he had a couple good lines that me
too he had some it was fun
What did he say I'm tried oh he said
you're tall
he said Sam loves basketball and you
know that because he's tall something
and he doesn't know who his father is
they leave you in there
no they just [ __ ] cut the whole scene
oh okay yeah I got cut out of the
Shandling doc I like Garry Shandling I
remember the first time I saw him was
when he was Joan Rivers was guest roast
guest hosting the Tonight Show and he he
did his thing and I remember they cut
him off in the middle of this final joke
it's a small world and he came back and
finished it on panel it's really what I
think that the music cue was off he
so [ __ ] funny oh so funny IRA Sanders
is like top five shows everything I
definitely watch it but everyone says
yeah it's amazing
colds up hard - it really does yeah and
you just watch episode after episode
after episode every character dude Rip
Torn Jeff yeah or they're all it's as
good a sitcom as it was maybe it's on
the HBO app now but like it wasn't at
first and so I bought like all the DVDs
- it was like you still have them yeah
dope why have man what's his name sign
did not not a Gary
Jeffrey Tambor Jeffrey Tambor signed it
you know is he in trouble now what
happened with him he's not I mean he's
not doing the show parent thing anymore
women like yeah yeah show now though
without he's the whole show it it
sounded to me when I heard what he they
said he did unless there was more but it
sounded like the way a guy and unless he
his assistant said he was like hitting
on her or whatever but it's he's the
dry-humped one of them good girls but I
don't know he was doing it to be serious
or he was this you wait for take YouTube
noxious ly doing it to be fun well the
issue is that like he was running around
everywhere being like an advocate for
everything and being outspoken and
seriously and do the and it's like their
key there you can't have room for an
ounce of hypocrisy before they get you
yeah he was here was an unpleasant or
it's unfortunate - can I like to be is
such a big bomb do the show anymore
wouldn't do anymore yeah yeah and I just
recently watched your Nancy Grace
YouTube she might not come back
that was tense yeah edge of my seat yeah
she had ugly little hands we kind of
couldn't believe that she was doing the
show we was like you gave so many times
you guys went Nancy Grace we were like
yeah yes she's not coming in here like
to the moment we wouldn't even announce
that she was coming on because we were
convinced she had blocked me on Twitter
already I think she did confront me too
she goes also he talks like she thought
she was gonna be this pissed and I'm
like good because I don't like her I
didn't like her it didn't worked out
well for her no not at all to anything
I'm afraid to what is that one where
she's dancing dancing dancing with the
pigs
ah yes she does have a Paula Deen thing
yeah she really does
she's unpleasant lady yeah yeah she good
she belongs in your same category as
Jesse Ventura yes he won't do the show
Wow because you fought with him yeah
cares yeah come on it's really
interesting because the probably the
worst fight I ever saw you get into on
the air with somebody was Jericho and
you and Jericho or pals we are yeah what
do you guys fight about
there was this was the first time he was
on I met Patrice was on that day too
yeah it was at the old XM studio and
Chris was in I think his book had just
come out yeah his first one I think yes
and I knew who he was of course right I
wasn't that familiar with him but he was
saying something I forget how
Christopher Reeves name came up he was
doing like he's doing a Christopher
Reeves foundation like yeah was hockey
thing it was some ice skating Wow oh
here we go this is Sol yeah yeah and
then and then Jim was about to make a
joke about Christopher Reeves and then
Jericho was like don't do it man don't
do it and Jim like almost like looked at
him like what the [ __ ] like don't do it
and then he did it like specifically at
that point and then it became a thing
yeah I did like Anthony laughs yeah and
then it became is Chris and there's me
like Jarrett Rhys Jericho doesn't put up
with [ __ ] though no yeah yeah a good
friend of mine today right he's a good
dude but he does not put up with [ __ ]
now this is when it was all clipped out
who's before like the whole thing
yes the old studio and it was before we
aired like full stuff on YouTube these
were just clips it was just like a
three-minute version of what was a much
longer clip yeah yeah man I miss that
old studio that's thing about Opie he
loved that drama like yeah he wanted to
keep that going like Michael Madsen
threatened to beat my ass
I get that though honestly like it works
we didn't really see eye to eye on
things but with with certain feel like I
I agree with him on that like it is
compelling when people are getting into
it like you gotta let that kind of go on
boy sure Michael Madsen was in here and
he told me that he told me I was a liar
because I told him I'd never hit a woman
I mean I've never had and I didn't
nobody right there is like incredible
like be you know how people say like oh
when you do this when you do that it
normalizes abuse to it like he literally
was like that's a normal thing Wow yeah
for that part in Reservoir Dogs yeah
usually I was like no I've never I've
never no never news I could full of [ __ ]
damn okay whenever you see Michael
Madsen Travis a clip the Jericho clip oh
where is I actually played in a
celebrity Christopher Reeve used to have
a celebrity game at the garden I played
four years with it it was great but the
one year I asked my dad Jimmy my dad
Christopher Reeve in a wheelchair could
still kick your ass
someone's friend like that yeah well
that's true but he was a very famous guy
and you know we we poked fun at it gets
his ass kicked 1/8 right after these
were the host of the show the your
bosses yes are being respectful bosses
you gotta cross the line when I say
don't say it well I wasn't being
disrespectful yes you were I was this
close to being disrespected Jimmy jumped
on on it first but first of all you
didn't say you a fragile them you just
say you played in the toy I'm just give
just kidding with you man I was actually
gonna go okay see which I could see your
wheels spinning when he said that I was
gonna go on three assaults I think
that's where that's right that's where
it gets from treaters nobody got heated
for a while it wasn't right but anyway
it went up and down like there was some
harboring resentment yes I did feel bad
about because they they were friends and
I didn't know that Chris's mom had been
I think paralyzed by some abusive guy
like he had no reason to be hurt but I
didn't know that at the time I've never
been a great WWE storyline though that
paralyzes your mom you're like aw dude
but I wouldn't have I wouldn't have you
know he said it's somebody who's friends
with a guy and you know that
conversation really hit a hurdle you got
a do it I feel like it's That moment
when you don't know you just fire it out
yeah he and I had an argument and the
next time I saw him remember Lynn
caplets had that show was a music show
z0z Rock yeah and I didn't episode of
that and Chris was there what he was no
he was on the episode Jericho yeah and
we kind of made up I think we made up on
the radio somewhere I was weird but then
we kind of got to know each other and
yeah he became actually a good friend of
mine yeah he's a good guy yeah you know
it's a silver platter it's like a
Stephen Hawking thing you know you got
to do it's one of those things where
like Christopher Reeve was so famous and
the incident of Superman having this
actually you know of course you forget
like in the moment you don't care that
it's a real human being with feel or
some joke plus you got challenged a
little bit yeah don't do it don't do it
you're like now it's like that's all it
takes for a comment of course yeah me
and after damn I'll never forget me and
Anthony sit there kind of look and I had
to do it for antha I couldn't not do it
cuz he was like oh yeah man remember
back in the day like I remember in
college I went to a Halloween party and
the costumes used to be so offensive
this guy came up in a wheelchair with a
Superman I saw that in New York in the
street yes yes I was like that guy's a
cool guy I've ever thinking he was like
the life of the party was like great but
now that would be blogged and you know
because everything gets everything
social media now yes but he was like
getting high fives at this party those
days everybody didn't commit to his
costume it's another guy on Twitter
sorry I know and like Jim's comedy but
if this was a serious tweet then he's
dead to me forever tweets when I find
out Jim is coming from this is serious
town and so I owe them something on a
free platform where you're just giving
out jokes I can I look at his profile he
goes animal lover great sense of humor
Oh guys [ __ ] relax everything is not
a bigger statement about a larger subway
I know sometimes it's just a joke yeah
like if you need a joke so you can jump
off on your soapbox then just admit I'm
gonna use this to springboard into what
I want to say yeah but don't put it on
me yeah just write honest right went on
Twitter seems like a gender driven like
- I just want this to fit what they
wanted to you right they want to talk to
this mm-hmm
just enjoy the joke it's or don't like
it okay well yeah but don't don't make
it look like it's some serious you know
it's a call for anarchy yeah just being
a sweet boy John sterling said still got
his calls that's just a cute thing at a
baseball game it's not a cute
she here the last John sterling god I
mean do you guys like John sterling ooh
Yankee announcer he's the one who does
all those famous home run call like that
but you know his home run calls are
atrocious what are they they're the ones
that like he's famous for eating a bomb
from a ride back to the back and a
belly-to-belly like he does a cute
nicknames for every single player and
plan words to the point where clearly
he's just getting himself over like it
has nothing to do with making sure that
you experience the action on the field
just
like he makes it the John sterling show
yeah time in there he's the worst
yeah do we have that it was from sure
who was saying yesterday yeah yeah
because it was over the weekend it was a
Giancarlo Stanton yeah which previously
he called it stayin Tony n' yep say that
as if that was a thing it's real awful
that's not good so is he doing alright
now he was struggling when Anton no I I
just I only know when there's a bad home
run call I can't watch yeah we go based
on the John sterling calls and that's it
apparently he's hitting home runs
because we're listening to it thank God
thank God is right yeah
thank thank the Lord Almighty above
we're gonna go get in the file a clip
pulling up the club area this is old
school what do you in doc yes crazy well
what operator yeah Harrigan Carlo who
flied to Center his first time pitch
swung on and drilled a neat right video
that balls hi Dennis Park is fine
giancarlo
nan de medica that ball sure traveled
far giancarlo to run blast a stand Tony
in home run and the Yankees take a 4-2
it's like it's what about you open it's
not about you and he's not Italian no
Giancarlo Stanton now he's doing stuff
in Italian it's not Italian I don't know
why he'll get all riled up it's just a
cute thing at a baseball game but it's
not cute is it you a man it's not a cute
you know [ __ ] eight-year-old
precocious redhead at a party right it's
embarrassing when you're sitting with
your driving in your car right and your
wife is sitting next to you and you're
like let me listen to the game and this
guy comes on and goes run she's like
what are you listening to
usually not like this honey it's you it
usually just says the stuff he doesn't
sing baseball seems like that sport
where you go kind of crazy in the box
too like in there alone in such a boring
game we're gonna have for some of these
games we have a person on with you I
mean he's got a call Susan Wallman yeah
but he likes to ignore her a lot of
times he does she's on the pay no mind
list oh yeah when it comes time and over
here on third base yeah he doesn't like
he has somebody in there with him and he
doesn't like that there's somebody in
there with him Wow well he's 79 is he
snow he's not that he's old he's not 80
years old give it a Google 7900 my 79 he
looks pretty [ __ ] good for 79 p7 do
you know yeah do you see the Joe paw
movie did you I think but she has to be
nominated for something for that he was
so good I heard it's a great movie don't
tell me how it ends do you like it I'm
loving it so far but I dozed off I
watched it last night yeah yeah the
acting is really really good it's our
Firebird
it's heavy
Hey look I mean it is it is wait really
does it was so good but you don't left
to his up
yeah it's Pacino on the left wow you
know it's fun I watched half of heat
recently - I just wanted really I didn't
like it when I first saw it but this
time around I actually did enjoy all
right Markey half movies
yeah that's me then we should've been a
longer shootout scene there with those
cops which one such an action movie it's
such a like a jerk-off you know no one
talks a lot everybody so troubled and
angry it's great
well Anthony our own Anthony [ __ ] [ __ ]
look at me something I didn't know
excited always wonder why his Pacino
yelling in that give me my god but then
they someone said that the character was
supposed to do coke there's some reason
I don't know it didn't make it till the
final script or maybe they put it in and
then they cut the seat I don't know what
it was yeah but that made more sense
yeah she's got a great ass yeah I mean I
was like why is he doing this yeah
that's the directors pretty good though
man my good man but you know look a
little weird that's how you know HBO has
done a good job with the paterno movie
that it just goes to heat five minutes
five seconds of Paterno time in two
heats eternal I think I like the
Kevorkian movie better it was great yeah
it wasn't as funny but it was good yeah
I think you don't know jackets called
yeah not the best title but a good movie
Phil Spector I think you know what I
like the Phil Spector movie better than
the paterno movies doing all the HBO
movies hates me those are all chinos
Phil Spector those are all HBO movies
what's the spectre what's the story
there with Spectre he was a cute really
with overwhelming heaven in the mouth
accused Wow accused I don't think he's
found in jail no he's in prison
oh that's right he claimed he was not
guilty yeah well yeah yeah
a real piece of [ __ ] I mean he really
limey nice ID from that like he would
just he had a loaded gun always in
recording sales wall of sound my friend
he would do whatever he wants yeah
murder yes let me hear him Pacino Pacino
in the Phil Spector wig is the greatest
actually that was Jeffrey Gurian he was
so good I never seen Phil the real one
oh my god it's still pretty petite but
it's great it's great but it's still
pretty Pacino
but he's so his mouth is different yeah
he's so good man he's good have you seen
Simone all right I can't but he's good
enough to a real actor can change his
voice no real actor just takes that's go
embodiment Karen's call those people
from the wire they had to change their
accent that's right he didn't though he
sounds like Phil Spector yeah I mean I
think he's also great as [ __ ] Roy
Cohen he plays so many different people
what's going on he was a gay lawyer with
HIV and angels in America oh he's
Trump's uh mentor what yeah Roy Cohn he
was at Trump is very very looked up to
Roy Cohn along he was a ruthless guy
interesting gay mm-hmm gay and died of
HIV I remember you threatened his doctor
in the movie I'll see you if you say
because a guy gave him okay I think the
guy said you have HIV from anal sex or
some [ __ ] like that
nice ooh I'll sue you damn it's not a
great story but I mean you know ruthless
guy he's working for marthy yeah yeah
he's really ruthless guy oh I'm nervous
former mentor and fix her to handle
Russia probe now he's got
Michael calling different spelling is he
dating R'lyeh he's dead boy :
yeah me oh yeah Hades 19:27 okay yeah
there's a present yeah he died maybe sex
okay Bronx guy four of us just staring
sorry
pictures of them and you say Bronx guy
all stumped I think it's but I think
none of us knew who Roy Cohn was that's
a hilarious people also search for
joseph mccarthy and then jeffrey wright
iversity why Jeffrey Wright
it's probably an Angels in America